mha just exploded out of control as all
for one Unleashed his ultimate final
attack people are going to die the world
is shaking and after this things will
never be the same this is even darker
than I imagined so let's talk about it
right now you guys know the drill if you
enjoy my mha content you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment for that YouTube algorithm
and if you want to help this channel
awaken the true power of its Quirk by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are so close finally this video will of
course contain M manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the last chapter gave us one
of the darkest backstories in the entire
series as we found out the tragic truth
about all for one and his brother yoichi
we also got the true history of quirks
and we learned that the luminescent baby
the person credited with manifesting the
first quirk in history wasn't the first
after all there were others who
manifested quirks before him but the
quirks were either missed completely or
falsely class classified as illnesses
all for one himself had a quirk over a
year before the luminescent baby was
even born and he was so peeved with the
baby getting all the credit and gaining
millions of supporters because of it
that he killed him and stole the Quirk
now the younger brother yoichi wanted to
believe that all for one had a good side
to him and that he could be redeemed but
it was hopeless Olan decided that he
would become a Demon Lord someone whom
everyone fears and reveres and who sees
the entire world as his own private
property eventually you II decided to
fight against his brother's tyranny and
when he got the chance to leave with
Kudo and the other members of the
resistance he did however at some point
Al foran murdered his younger brother
because he decided that if yichi
wouldn't be his property then he
wouldn't get to exist at all Al foran
destroyed his brother's body and only
yoichi's hand remained intact the latest
chapter continues this dark backstory
but then it relates it all back to the
present and it leads up to all for one
using his ultimate World crushing attack
the activation of every single one of
his Quirk factors at the same time which
creates a grotesque monstrosity that
threatens to destroy everything
including all for one himself but first
we get the confirmation that all for one
did indeed kill his brother with his own
hands all for one was the one who gave
his brother his name yoichi written with
the kanji for give and won the name
symbolizes the fact that yichi was all
for one's first possession and when
yichi tried to run away from his brother
and join the resistance all for one
decided to kill him rather than allow
him to break free of all for one's
control yuichi's death seems to have
occurred only about 2 months after he
ran away from all for one with the help
of the second and third one for all user
we see a scene in the sewers where yichi
is killed by all for one while dozens of
other members of the resistance
including the second and third user are
trying to get away from the villain all
for one hated the second user Kudo
because he felt that Kudo had stolen his
property by convincing his brother to
abandon him all for one's naturally
empty and unreflective eyes locked on to
Kudo and he remembered that defiant look
in kudo's Eyes Forever we then see ol
foran sitting inside a massive penthouse
on top of a large building and managing
his vast criminal Empire honestly I'm
glad we got a glimpse of all for one
back when he was at the top of the food
chain because this is exactly how I
imagined him like a superpowered mixture
between a mob boss and a business tycoon
we see all for one holding yoichi's hand
the only part of his brother's body that
survived his attack the hand has been
preserved in the same way that the hands
of tomur shigaraki's family would be
preserved later and actually that got me
thinking when over for one kills yoichi
it kind of looks like he's decaying his
brother's body the Decay doesn't spread
to the other Rebels because they are
running through a wet sewer and Decay
only spreads through solid surfaces but
I think this might be it this might be
the final proof we need to confirm the
theory that Al foran possessed The Quirk
Decay and that he secretly gave it to
little tenko shimura back when tenko was
5 years years old tenko then
accidentally killed his entire family
because he couldn't control this new
Quirk and so he became the ideal
candidate to be groomed for becoming all
for one's new vessel I've made an entire
video about this Theory which breaks
down all the clues and hints that we
have gotten over the past hundreds of
chapters so if that's something you're
interested in check out that video link
in the description while holding
yoichi's hand all for one realizes that
when his brother was killed his body no
longer contained his Quirk Factor even
though all for one knows for a fact that
he gave a powerful quirk toichi for some
reason the Quirk was now gone and this
is something that had never happened
before this is the moment when all from
one first realizes that yoichi did have
a quirk all along it was just a very
weak one all for one theorizes that
yoichi's Quirk might have been weak
because he stole the vast majority of
nutrients from his twin brother while
still in the womb which may have stunted
not only yoichi's physical growth but
also the growth of his Quirk Factor
ultimately all for one realizes that his
brother had the ability to transfer his
Quirk to someone else and once once his
original Quirk combined with the
stockpiling Quirk that all for one had
given him yoichi willingly transferred
the new Quirk one for all to the second
user Kudo this is then confirmed after
the third user whose name is apparently
Bruce runs some tests on Kudo the tests
indicate that the second user now has
two Quirk factors his original one and
the second small one that he received
from yoichi this tells us that upon
first being transferred to the second
user one for all was still extremely
weak and it only grew stronger much
later as it stockpiled more and more
power over the course of nine
Generations Kudo took this to mean that
yoichi's will still lives inside of him
and it inspired him to fight even harder
for the resistance meanwhile the
extremely possessive all for one took
this as a personal affront how dare Kudo
steal something that belongs to him yet
again first his brother and now his
brother's Quirk factor and from this day
forward the villain became determined to
get his brother's Quirk Factor back back
we then see a collage of all for one
fighting against all the different one
for all users and killing them but he
fails to get one for all back again and
again this went on until one day all
might came into possession of one for
all and with the quk having stockpiled
tons of power over the course of like
100 plus years all might was finally
able to defeat All For One the villain
was apparently left for dead after the
battle all might believed that he had
actually killed all for one the
villain's body was literally placed in a
body bag and taken to the morg but then
uo managed to get a hold of the body and
it was he who managed to revive the
villain and helped him to recover now I
don't know if this means that all for
one was actually dead and uo literally
revived him kind of like obodo shirakumo
or if all for one was just still alive
but everyone thought he was dead like he
was presumed dead but he was still
Clinging On To Life or something it's an
interesting question because if all for
onean really died and uo brought him
back from the dead wouldn't that
technically make him some kind of no
move let me know in the comments what
you think is all for one actually a nomu
now and while you're at it don't forget
to like And subscribe to support your
boy moving on we then finally return to
the present moment and all for one is
basically losing his mind he screams out
that everything is kudo's fault and he
keeps wondering whether bakugo and Kudo
could be somehow related because bakugo
reminds him so much of the second one
for all user however this seems
impossible since all for one apparently
not only killed Kudo but also his entire
family like literally anyone who was
even related to Kudo in any way was
disposed of that is just how sick and
twisted all for one is and how psychotic
he becomes when something that he
believes belongs to him is taken away in
the end the villain seems to conclude
that the thing that bakugo and Kudo
share is that confident and defiant look
in their eyes so much so that bakugo
looks like he's carrying out kudo's will
like he is trying to finish what Kudo
started at this point all for one is
beginning to panic not only is he
traumatized by kudo's Will seemingly
returning in the form of bakugo but he
can also feel that if he continues to
fight he is going to become too young
and he won't be able to accomplish his
mission shigaraki is already fighting
back so he needs to save some of his
strength in order to force shigaraki to
become his vessel all for one kept
thinking that he has to hold back
against bakugo and save some of his
energy for the transfer of his Quirk
factor into shigaraki but now he
suddenly changes his mind instead of
conserving energy he will concentrate
all of his remaining energy into one
final move it is a move that will
destroy bakugo and blast all for one
right to shigaraki's location all in one
shot and so the villain activates his
ultimate move he activates every single
Quirk factor that he has collected over
the generations he initiates a full
Factor release Al one's body suddenly
morphs into a grotesque mutation that
looks like something out of a horror
movie as the bodies of everyone whose
quirks over one had stolen seem to
emerge out of his own body the mutation
kind of reminds me of the philosopher
stone from FMA Brotherhood but somehow
even creepier he kind of looks like Envy
final form in FMA but less green anyway
you get the idea the villain's decision
to unleash all the Quirk factors at once
initiat some kind of massive explosion
that begins to annihilate entire city
blocks within a matter of seconds a
horrified all might screams at bakugo to
dodge but despite this immense show of
force by all for one bakugo isn't scared
at all he actually smirks calls the
villain stupid and assures him that he
is definitely going to lose man bakugo
is seriously a chatter for this because
I'm creeped out just looking at all for
one's attack as a black and white manga
panel and Baku goes over there facing
down the whole thing directly and he
isn't even phased by it this is it for
all for one this is his make or break
moment either he succeeds with this
final attack and takes over shigaraki's
body or he is reduced to a sniveling
baby and he is defeated once and for all
my money is on him being defeated and
then shigaraki becoming the final
villain on his own but let me know if
you agree or disagree down in the
comments what happens next will bakugo
andu survive all for one's attack will
shigaraki finally have to fight his own
Master is all for one about to be
wearing a literal diaper oh and what if
I told you that shigaraki was actually
born quirkless and the K was secretly
given to him by all for one in order to
get him to accidentally kill his family
and become all for one's vessel oh
what's that I already did say that
earlier in the video well now you can
watch my full video on this theory that
looks like it's about to be confirmed
link on screen and in the description if
you enjoyed this mha video and you want
to see more in the future leave a like
to let me know and if you want to help
this channel awaken the full power with
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
do me a huge favor and subscribe right
now we are so close